seven minutes past four Las Vegas is no  stranger to freelance jobs on the strip  and off of it around the holidays gig  work is becoming a more popular way to  earn extra cash the freelance and gig  economy has grown Nationwide since the  pandemic it can be a good option for  stay-at-home parents and students who  need a flexible schedule Alex Atwood is  CEO of gravy work and she spoke about  how her platform helps find these jobs  when you apply to gravy work or you  apply to a lot of the gig economy apps  out there what happens is the whole  application process is all done while  you're onboarding through downloading  the app so you're answering all the  questions you need you're adding it  references in real time and it's done in  such a way that makes it just super  simple  right now hotels restaurants event  venues are all searching for additional  staff and we have additional details at  8newsnow.com